you
[Music]
it's gotta be three o'clock that's when
the light hits my bowl and that really
beautiful way reminding me that I'm all
alone
Claire don't believe in God God wouldn't
treat any living creature the way I've
treated loan in a bowl with only my own
poo to float around with as a friend
what if I was a praying fish I would
pray for death every day please Jesus
please be real for just a few seconds
and never kill me first didn't kill all
the sinners and argon older Lord take my
[ __ ] spleen out if you have to maybe
I'm sleeping and I choke up my food
that's floating around listen I'll make
you a deal I'll even let you crushed me
in your Jesus Anders long as I don't
slip out my little nail ha ha ha ha
I'm sorry if that annoyed you or
offended you I don't want to thank you
but if that helps you kill me then yeah
I offend you
I dream that I'm being splashed should
someone pick me up and throw me in a
bowl to oblivion
[Music]
[Music]
I don't even Ilham dream where I'm
trying to give my older to put me on the
stove like make them so mad
but being like happy with pizzas [ __ ]
I've seen you jerk off to Guinea porn
I'm telling them telling your girlfriend
tickets check only then will I know true
that it is boiling alarm
you see this little baby this little
divot anything I've been a little
worried about others before but this
finish to me we've got me I've dreamed
up yeah I need to deny others get a
dremel cleaning it into a little girl
Feeney driving like well
you